let's go to our caller from the 703 area
code who's calling today from 7:03 or
can you hear me yes I can okay oh yeah
your audios victus a lot better um so
hey David I was just wondering um you've
mentioned a lot that a large problem the
US has is not being respected by our
allies yes and I was just wondering how
you would get people specifically like
on the right to prioritize that because
a lot of people you know that I know
don't really think that you know we
should be respected or you know don't
really think it's worth it they don't
care anyway yeah well like not they
don't care
you know they it's like you know they
actively actively don't want to be like
respected as a country which cuz they
just think that Europeans and Canadians
like to hate them so like why should why
should they even bother you know like
how do we how would we like in theory
get rid of that yeah I mean some of some
of them actually see it as a badge of
honor they're like why do we care if the
Europeans like us we don't want them to
like us that means we're doing what's
good for America I mean listen I I
hesitate to ever recommend trying to
appeal to the rights values because
their values are often so misguided but
I wonder would the right care more about
the u.s. being respected around the
world if they saw it as a national
security issue like if they if they were
convinced that we are safer by being
respected around the world then maybe we
could get them to understand the
importance of not being a laughingstock
I don't I mean I'm thinking out loud
here I don't know the answer yeah before
you actually you know trying and very
like get respected by the rest of the
world which you know in reality is
mainly just Europe you have to you know
convince you know people that hey this
is actually something that's worthwhile
and I think you know you have to do that
first so pause the country doesn't tell
actively you know doesn't really want to
be respected and I mean you can't really
you can't really now pursue a policy
that you know you know get the u.s. you
know respected around the world again
because you know it's just kind of
fruitless but I totally agree I mean you
have a so so for example you know on
climate change under Donald Trump the
u.s. is increasingly not even invited to
take part in some of the important
multinational conversations that are
happening about that but that doesn't
bother the right you know a huge part of
the right thinks climate change is a
hoax another part of the right believes
that the US can just fix every problem
by ourselves a sort of isolationist
mentality so we don't need to be part of
these multinational conversate
multilateral conversations so you are
100% right that if they don't care it's
not going to be any it's not going to be
a bargaining stick if they don't care
about being respected to begin with my
pleasure thank you for the call great to
hear from you